[Musique]
sakho didier delanis la vie te dit tout
les gens qui vont bosser à rome là j'ai
jamais eu aussi peu de bagnols
premier humain que je vois à pied
j'ai l'impression que là et la police
locale qui est venu vérifier si les
règles étaient respectées dans ce
supermarché
donc voilà on fait tout cela que devant
pour aller faire les courses
je vais leur demander la levée ou non ce
sont nos françaises et paris orly et
audio chili c'est trop fort non
[Musique]
ok ok
et sinon sur la certification n'est
qu'une seule fois la queue commencé ici
au
non mais c'est une blague ou non mais
attends je vais pas faire tout 7 q à
quoi ça continue derrière les voitures
et tous
[Musique]
je
les masculins et puis c'est le cas
puisque rockabilly et il avait bon dos
mais peut se laisser menotter et une
alternative à permet
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de personnes en fait qui
vont au ce qu'on appelle le phénomène
toile à la rmn tos et des magasins de
bricolage et en fait comme il ya plus de
masques dans les pharmacies dans les
supermarchés des gens ont fait prenez
des masques de bricolage mais même s'il
y en a plus masculine elle
et voilà que ça ressemble
[Musique]
voilà
bach qui fonctionne bien logiquement
pour les apéros
ils sont en train de fermer
bon ben voilà à quoi ressemble l'école
en ce moment ça qu arnaud on reçoit les
devoirs en fait de la part des
maîtresses des enfants sur l'ordinateur
devenant auto ben m quoi sinon les et
stx et la fin d'une guerre contre la
lectura et ben milot misterioso
divination de délai demandé par dois je
vous rappeler les professeurs quoi au
fait
ça va ouais ton texte il est bien tu
préfère être ici ou à l'école ici au
moyen d'un hacker content tu préfères
l'école ouais c'est pas évident il faut
faire trois heures de cours par jour
on a fait combien ton avis
il est meilleur donc on est loin du
compte il faut encore bosser
voilà je suis allé marcher un petit peu
là dans la campagne au bord du village
parce que rester à la maison ça commence
vraiment à être un peu un peu raide
à l'aller 19 heures c'est la fin de
cette première journée de confinement on
sait pas combien de temps ça va encore
durer cette aventure c'est inquiétant là
pour la première fois là je me rends
vraiment compte que c'est pour de vrai